hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play incredible now
this was recommended to me because
people saw me play a herbal space
program and they thought that I might
like different games like this this is
actually a free-form building game even
though it may not seem like it at first
but you will see what I'm talking about
in just a little bit continue I haven't
played the game yet so play official
levels normals light and fun let's go I
thought that said hard is good meaning
you don't need to be demeaning to me I
already know I'm bad little quarter was
playing happily with the resistors she'd
never left her family's village by the
sea until the day the great ships
arrived men came out and forced her
sisters on to the ships
[Music]
her village was burned and everyone was
taken away little Kwas all fled into the
hills
[Music]
there were rumors of another village
across the island
wazzle will have to be brave and clever
to get to the distant village and save
her sisters all right hope you enjoyed
my little bit of a narration there so
basically from what I've seen from the
videos the trailers and whatnot you are
causal apparently and you have an
amalgamation of limbs and strange
oddities and you move based accordingly
oh my goodness what in the world well I
was gonna say you move logically
according to your structure but this is
anything but logical my word one the
world who designed that one that could
not have been anything okay basically
you start out with a body center the eye
is the center so you build off of that
based on legs and muscles I got the two
cherries which are part of that one and
this game is proven to be quite
interesting and weird I thought that I
was gonna be building this from what I
saw in the maybe it's best if I don't
because I don't know what little quasi
was doing but why she's really changing
up her structure a lot whenever she
decides to go from level to level so I'm
not exactly sure why or how but
apparently I think they're just trying
to show me the different methods of
locomotion and what they do like those
long legs were obviously good
- cause gaps and whatnot and go into the
light to cross gaps and doodads and
whatever and each each level is its own
puzzle and ergo you have to use your
methods of locomotive any sense that hey
I'm stuck come here hey
what not that's not what I wanted to do
at all what is going on okay I got a
lake
wrench together and then push myself up
and then oh my gosh I'm stuck how did I
get stuck what did I do to deserve this
I'm just a simple little quaza l-- maybe
I'll get there eventually no it was
working before what'd I do wrong maybe I
gotta flip myself
aha suck on that yeah I am too pro to be
stopped by simple physics the laws of
physics need not apply to me anyway
there's a bunch of different levels to
this game I'm only gonna do one more
if you fail hit the loop button to try
ghetto whoa doin breakdancing here
excuse me for a second while I calibrate
my own right back here
what the hell you didn't I don't wanna
go into the light I wanted to get
alright whatever next
actually what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
go into the sandbox I'm just doing this
as a little preview to you guys because
I want I like to give ideas to these
indie games this is an indie game that's
available on Steam and it's really
imaginative and I really like it but now
we're gonna be building our own little
creature because you can build your own
Wow what didn't sound good Oh grody so
you create message of low cat wait you
create message of locomotion and you
catch muscle what I'll try to oh okay
okay yeah that's yeah it's normal
oh my done wrong this little creature
did not deserve this not at all my
goodness what am i doing what sort of
horrifying thing about creating here oh
my god I should not be the creator of
anything oh the bane oh no I'm doing a
dance apparently my goodness what the
hell
okay note to self I really got nothing
to say because this is just awful
I'm falling now I fell that was
terrifying okay let me um let me try
that again how do I delete these things
was that I can't see this yeah okay
let's go back into here alright let me
actually read these stretch legs yeah Oh
click the dragon quash away from causal
body click back in to remove the leg
click the pink muscle bulge tan then
choose a flashing muscle to delete click
the muscle then click X shift B deletes
everything alright then what alright so
let's try to get something simple let's
get some legs normal everyday looking
legs right right that's one leg and
there's the second leg looking pretty
good hüseyin bolt eat your heart out all
right and let's get some pumping arms in
there getting a swole going you did make
sure that these are nice and attached
several different muscular strands oh I
chose ok hang on
that one's a flexor and that one's in
extends or flexor extends or no extent
extend or flexor extensor alright this
seems pretty logical let's go oh god no
what the hell what am i gun stop
okay shifty that didn't work let's try
this again a different way I'm gonna try
a four legged creature cuz that's what
works best
everyone knows four legs where it's at
okay
alright now these muscles need to attach
okay the front ones are all
counterclockwise and clockwise I got it
so the front ones need this feels like
I'm developing QWOP this probably the
guy that made coop was like
uh yeah that goes there and that goes
there and those go counterclockwise or
clockwise my counter clock no need to go
the other way
yup that's gonna work kept squarish oh
we can't we finally got some movement a
little bit of a dance going on but and
right off the wrong end well good for
you buddy it's just cuz you were a
little - no get out of here what are you
doing yeah here it's cuz the back legs
need to be the more efficient propulsion
that can hey hey hey hey no time for the
Cossack let's go what in the world are
yes just keep moving that's it that's it
you're doing it you're doing it little
buddy you're doing it you're making me
proud of you
it somehow works yeah I'm the greatest
designer of anything Oh God
alright anyway let's try to make this a
little bit less stupid shifty I'm gonna
try to make hang on let me we're gonna
big can we make these okay we can make
these pretty darn big so I'm just gonna
start throwing random things crisscross
and um sorry little buddy I know this is
probably not what you were looking for
in terms of a life why we make do with
the best that we got so you've got to
make do with me because I am in charge
here and you are gonna be some kind of
Christmas tree I have officially decided
that you're gonna be perfectly normal
yeah perfectly normal nothing to see
here
everything is a-okay so thanks for
asking okay let's give this a try got
balance
oh ma I'm an accordion I'm a dancing
flailing amalgamation of sticks my god
it's kind of oddly beautiful in a way
wouldn't you say
and basically even though that I'm a
biomedical engineer and I understand the
basic principles of anatomy and
physiology I could wor heart is going on
I wasn't even paying attention this is
this is beautiful
that was amazing that actually what
didn't work but it was good
so anyway I'm done playing God for now
I'm gonna get out of here so anyway that
is incredibly incredibly is a mixture of
a sandbox and a puzzle game it's
actually really fun I might play this on
my own later I'm not gonna make a series
about it so I'll check it out on Steam
you can find it there it's only ten
dollars I think and if you think that's
too much it'll probably go on sale at
some point so keep on keep it on your
wish list or something so thank you all
so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]